[Music]
straight ahead on Law and crime daily
Scott Peterson awaits a decision on the
future of his case while he seeks a new
trial over alleged juror misconduct 20
years after the death of his wife Lacey
and their unborn son Connor plus jurors
here from defendant Paul Flores in
police interviews from 26 years ago in
the 1996 disappearance case of Kristen
smart and body cam footage shows the
moments police take a suspect into
custody as Muhammad Syed faces charges
in connection to several murders in a
Muslim Community in New Mexico but first
the stabbing death of Christian
obumselli we hear from his family's
former attorney as only fans model
Courtney klenny is charged with his
murder law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
foreign
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
I am your host Imran Ansari we got the
opportunity to sit down with the former
attorney for the family of a man stabbed
to death in April this comes as his
girlfriend only fans model and social
media influencer Courtney clenny is
awaiting extradition to Florida after
being arrested in connection with his
death clenny who goes by Courtney Taylor
for her more than 2 million followers on
social media was arrested in Hawaii on
Wednesday four months after the murder
in their Miami apartment she is charged
with second-degree murder in the
stabbing death of Christian obamselli
clenny's attorney insists the social
media influencer stabbed him in
self-defense after he grabbed her by the
throat the couple reportedly had a
history of domestic violence events even
some including the cops being called to
their residents though Friends of the
couple have given conflicting reports on
which one of them was abusive video
surfaced of one altercation between
clenny and obamselli in an elevator
where clenny is seen hitting her
boyfriend prosecutors say clenny had
previous bouts of aggression when the
couple lived in Austin Texas and after
they moved to Florida court documents
reveal interviews with Neighbors in
Miami who complained about the couple
arguing into the night uh on the night
an eviction notice was sought
obamacelli's family has pushed for
cliny's arrest since the April dabbing
they continued to demand answers civil
rights attorney Lee Merritt tells us he
believes the charges are justified in
this case
it seems more accurate now that you know
she was going after him she was looking
to hurt him and she was able to do that
on this day with a deadly weapon uh I
think she was appropriately charged with
second-degree murder a black man can be
the victim of a white woman we rarely
see that and I think that's the reason
we saw this four-month gap before an
arrest was made but I think the state
prosecutor is going out of her way to
say you know this is not about race or
bias or even poor police in the initial
investigation but this is about domestic
violence we have to call it what it is
in every case hats off to the family of
Christian Obama Sally who continued to
fight uh the Nigerian Community said
that that Christians should be treated
like any other victim and that a
thorough investigation should take place
and so they ran an independent
investigation of the three to four month
period before formal charges move
forward is is quite normal what we
normally see though is an initial arrest
which never took place here and so now
to see uh Miss clinic in cuffs in
custody in East Hawaii is a major
development
okay joining me today are law and crime
legal analyst Julie rendelman and
forensic deaf investigator Joe Joseph
Scott Morgan Julie I'm going to start
with you at first clenny was brought in
to give a statement but then released
because police believed it was
self-defense could that hurt the
prosecution's case once it goes to trial
it could you know if you're the attorney
what are you going to say you're going
to cross-examine each of the potential
detectives and police officers to
establish that they believed her at the
time so much so that they let her go and
kept her out for four months and they're
also going to push the narrative whether
true or not that it was only a political
reason that the prosecutor eventually
arrested her that it was the family that
was pushing to get her arrested of the
victim um and that's something it look
the jury will decide whether that
matters to them but that's something
they may consider
Joseph Scott Morgan I'm going to ask you
the next question we don't know how many
times obam Sully was stabbed but there
are reports it was in his shoulder
through an artery near his heart what
would the specifics of that mean for a
self-defense argument
I think that that's going to be hard to
prove initially she had stated that she
threw the knife at him and I got to tell
you this is not a throne knife event the
chief medical examiner stated that it
was a six inch blade that passed through
his chest three inches and clipped
what's referred to as the subclavian
artery or the subclavicular artery which
is just a fancy way of saying beneath
the collarbone and this is significant
because this artery if you're in
distress and they roll you into the
emergency room they go directly in to
that artery to put an IV in because it's
the quickest way to get drugs into your
body he would not have had a chance even
if he had had a team of cardiothoracic
surgeons standing by she clipped this
vessel and he began to bleed out and
most importantly the me is saying this
is a downward path that means that she
took the knife and drove it down like
this into his chest this is not rain on
or anything like that I I think that
this is going to be the second degree
fits this in my opinion yeah we're going
to be watching this case as it unfolds
in court and also in celebrity news the
investigation into the fatal shooting of
cinematographer Helena Hutchins on the
set of Alec Baldwin's movies rust inches
towards an end as the FBI finalizes its
forensic analysis of the incident
investigators say they are still waiting
to obtain Baldwin's phone records now
nearly nine months since the deadly
shooting it happened in May while the
actor was using a prop gun during a
rehearsal on the film set near Santa Fe
the gun Baldwin was holding had a live
ammunition round inside which went off
killing Hutchins and injuring film
director Joel Souza since the shooting
New Mexico's occupational health and
safety Bureau or OSHA find the
production company behind the film over
firearm safety violations Hutchins
family he also sued Baldwin and the
movie's producers but no one has been
criminally charged over the incident yet
investigators now must comb through a
recent report from the New Mexico Office
of Medical investigator once that's done
Ann Baldwin's phone records are received
the case will be sent to the district
attorney's office to determine if any
charges will be filed and against who
and Russia confirms for the first time
that they are in negotiation talks with
the U.S officials over the possible
prisoner exchange of WNBA player
Brittany Greiner Greiner was arrested in
February after Moscow airport officials
discovered she was carrying two Vape
cartridges containing cannabis oil which
is illegal in Russia Greiner asked the
court for leniency and pleaded guilty to
the charges but she was ultimately
sentenced to more than nine years in
prison last week on charges of drug
possession and drug smuggling last month
the Biden Administration made a proposal
to Russia to facilitate greiner's return
and former U.S marine Paul Whalen who
has been held since 2018 on Espionage
charges which he has repeatedly denied
the possible trade could include Russian
arms trafficker Victor bout who is
currently serving a 25-year prison
sentence in the United States
and still had on Long crime daily
veteran investigators describe a police
interview with defendant Paul Flores in
the 1996 disappearance case of Kristen
smart
but first a convicted white killer seeks
a new trial following alleged juror
misconduct the latest on the Scott
Peterson case coming up next
[Music]
foreign
ly after jurors here from the victim's
son in the re-sentencing case of Jason
Wheeler a man once again facing a
possible death sentence in the 2005
shooting death of a Florida Deputy
wheeler was convicted in 2006 of several
charges including first-degree murder a
year after he shot and killed Wayne
Kester in an apparent Ambush Deputy
Kessler responded to a neighborhood call
after a domestic violence complaint from
Wheeler's then girlfriend when deputies
arrived they were ambushed Kester was
shot in the head at close range two
other deputies were also shot after a
massive Manhunt wheeler was involved in
a second shootout with law enforcement
in which he was paralyzed he was
ultimately sentenced to death but that
sentence was overturned when Florida
ruled a death penalty recommendation
must be unanimous those close to the
victim were given an opportunity to
speak as part of the re-sentencing trial
kester's son gave it an emotional state
statement Friday afternoon
February 9005 my life changed forever
not a day goes by I don't think about
him
and if I'm doing right
or if he would even be proud of the men
I'd become
but I never knew
he will never be at my wedding
or see me with my first child
I'll never get to see him play with my
grandchildren
or have him sit and drink a beer with me
and just talk about life and I join the
Army
and I I took that path so that he would
hopefully be proud of me
and I hope he is proud of me
and I will have been missing
and convicted killer Scott Peterson now
awaits a decision from a judge whether
or not he will be granted a new trial in
the 2002 slangs of his wife Lacey and
their unborn son Peterson appeared in a
California court for one final hearing
as his attorneys argue for a new trial
over alleged juror misconduct his
attorneys claim juror Rochelle nice who
was nicknamed Strawberry Shortcake
because of her red hair lied on her
drawer questionnaire about being a
victim of domestic violence and said she
had been part of a lawsuit nice
testified during a hearing earlier this
year that she didn't lie because she
didn't consider herself a victim and
didn't consider the restraining order
granted to her a lawsuit at the end of
Court Thursday the judge told attorneys
they have until September 16th to submit
memorandums if they have any questions
after that she will have 90 days to come
back with a decision this was the first
time since 2003 that cameras have been
allowed in court for the Peter Anderson
case
now Joseph this crime happened 20 years
ago could there be any new forensic
evidence that the prosecution could
present if Peterson is given a new trial
that's going to be heavily dependent
upon
how they preserve they the authorities
preserved that evidence that they came
up with all the way back then remember
you know this evidence goes into an
Evidence locker and it sits there and if
we're thinking about things like DNA and
that sort of thing it has the tendency
to degrade over a period of time if it's
not kept perfectly and so that could be
a problem I can't imagine though that
there would be other items that have not
already been examined
that would bring anything else new to
light in Scott Peterson's case
yeah Julie if there is a new trial you
think they're going to allow cameras
inside that courtroom and will there be
these same media frenzy surrounding this
trial as we saw when the murder first
happened in that first trial
so that that would be a big if
um and so my guess is that they won't I
mean you know like I do Imran in New
York they don't allow it um and I'd be
surprised that they allowed again
they've allowed little bits of the
hearings to be broadcast I'm not so sure
that'll change in terms of the the media
I don't see it being the same as it was
all those years ago but but then again I
could be wrong
yeah and we have 90 days till that
Court's decision we're going to be
keeping tabs on what happens in that
case and coming up here on Long crime
daily jurors are shown interview footage
with the defendant from 26 years ago in
the case of Paul and Ruben Flores as
they face charges for The Disappearance
of Kristen smart
plus police body cam footage shows
officers taking a quadruple murder
suspect into custody what's next in the
quadruple murder case of Muhammad Saeed
thank you foreign
[Music]
testimony in the trial of Father and Son
Paul and Ruben Flores Over The
Disappearance of Kristen smart continued
despite three participants in the trial
testing positive for covid-19
the father and son are being tried in
the 1996 disappearance of smart who went
missing after a party around Memorial
Day Paul was reportedly the last person
seen with the Cal Poly student
prosecutors alleged he sexually
assaulted smart before killing her and
that his father buried her body in his
backyard before moving her elsewhere
nobody or remains have ever been found
Paul is charged with murder while Reuben
is charged with accessory after the fact
this week jurors were shown a police
interview with Paul the former
investigator who testified described
Paul's answers to questions that he said
the last time he saw smart she was
walking towards her dorm a second Deputy
testified Thursday and into Friday
Paul's defense attorney on
cross-examination questioned him about
the search on Paul's dorm room
all right let's break this down Julie
prosecutors have had 26 years to pile up
evidence against the suspect which
eventually pointed to Paul more than it
did right after her disappearance what
are the obstacles they are facing other
than time to convict Paul
at one of the big obstacles obvious
obstacles is obviously that we don't
have a body so we don't have a way of
proving exactly what caused her death we
don't have DNA we have very very limited
forensic evidence and we have no actual
eyewitnesses to her her death so 26
years plus these things makes it very
difficult for the prosecutor to move
forward with this case thankfully they
have statements that appear to be
inconsistent and that does take them a
step forward along with those cadaver
dogs to see what they have
Joseph Scott Morgan I want to get your
forensic sort of intake on this we
haven't heard the defense case yet what
should they focus on or who could they
point the finger to as an alternative
suspect
well I think that they've got an entire
student body that they could at least
you know point the finger at I'd like to
point the finger at the authorities from
Jump Street on this case because it was
a train wreck their response to her
disappearance initially being able to
get locations locked down and then
finally when you've collect evidence out
of these rooms I go back to what we had
talked about earlier
um how's that evidence been maintained
over this period of time and so you know
I think that there are more questions
than there are answers it's a shame that
we haven't found or they haven't found
her remains yet
um so hard to say but I think the
cadaver dogs play a big role in this
yeah a lot of time has passed hopefully
there will be some closure for this
smart family and also in California
after a late start Friday morning
testimony continued into its fourth day
into Kobe Bryant civil lawsuit brought
against Los Angeles County by his wife
Vanessa the lawsuit was filed following
Law Enforcement Officers sharing photos
of the crash which killed Kobe his
daughter Gianna and seven others after
their helicopter plunged into the side
of a hill in January of 2020. Vanessa
and another family is suing the county
after First Responders to graphic photos
at the crash site and allegedly shared
them with others outside the police and
fire departments testimony so far has
brought Vanessa to tears several times
on Thursday she walked out of court
while a bartender was on the stand
describing images he was shown by an
officer at the bar where he works
Vanessa asked the judge to leave after
he was asked if he had seen the body of
her daughter on Friday questioning
focused on the golden mic Awards gala
where County officials allegedly passed
around crash site photos
when we come back police released body
cam video in the arrest of Muhammad
Saeed a man charged in connection to the
murders of several Muslim men in New
Mexico
welcome back the two remaining officers
awaiting trial on state charges in the
death of George Floyd are scheduled to
face a judge on Monday tutau and Jay
Alexander King still face a state trial
on charges of aiding and abetting both
second-degree murder and second-degree
manslaughter in the May 2020 killing of
George Floyd when then officer Derek
shovin kneeled on his neck for more than
nine minutes killing him he was found
guilty of second degree murder and
sentenced to more than 22 years in
prison another former officer Thomas
Lane previously pleaded guilty to aiding
and abetting second-degree manslaughter
as part of a plea deal details of the
hearing haven't been released but what
we do know it's centered around the
status of King and Tao's plea
negotiations the four have already been
sentenced on federal civil rights
charges King Intel's trial is scheduled
for October the hearing Monday is set to
begin at 9 00 am
Albuquerque Police released body cam
video of the arrest of a man in
connection to the killings of four
Muslim men this is Muhammad Saeed makes
his first appearance in court
thanks to tips from the community
investigators were able to track down
the Volkswagen sedan allegedly driven by
the suspect in the most recent killing
and in turn arrested Saeed officials say
they have charged him in two of the
deaths Muhammad absal Hussain who was
found fatally shot in on August 1st and
aftab Hussein who was killed days
earlier on July 26th authorities are
working to connect the defendant to two
other murders 25-year-old naeem Hussein
who was killed last Friday and the first
murder of Mohammed Ahmadi last November
Saeed appeared in court this week over
video with an interpreter his attorney
advised him remaining silent would be in
his best interest authorities have not
yet determined a motive behind the
killings on Thursday police released the
body cam footage of his arrest more than
100 miles away from Albuquerque in Santa
Rosa Saeed is being held without bond
okay let's break this down Joseph I want
to go start with you investigators say
they found matching rounds in saeed's
car which matched up with two of the
victims murders what are other what
other evidence will they need Joseph in
order to connect him with the other
killings
well first I think that the ballistic
evidence is going to be key here they
did according to what I've read find one
weapon with him there may be another one
at his at his home where he was
currently domicile and so the ballistic
evidence is going to be significant
those rounds that are recovered from the
bodies of the victims if they can be
ballistically matched up as well as this
spent cartridges that were left behind
now I think another big point to this
we're all married to cell phones right
and how big is that his movements have
been tracked remember these are uh
different areas this didn't all occur in
one location I think electronic evidence
is going to play a huge role in it
right and this is going to be a case
that we are going to be tracking here at
long crime I want to thank you for
joining us here in the law of crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
[Music]
[Music]